Spider-man has some pretty sweet abilities,
but let us take a scientific look to see how well this superhero
stacks up to reality.
For spider-man to become genetically modified, the spider that
bit him would have to release a retrovirus into his body.
Retrovirus carry genetic information which
gets inserted into the DNA of cells.
The cell then reads the new DNA to create specific
functions and proteins for that cell.
But this retrovirus would have to make its way to nearly every cell
and have the ability to code for new
and different functions in each cell.
So while it is theoretically possible,
it would also be pretty "amazing".
Silk, it is actually proportionately stronger
and more flexible than steel.
Spiderwebs 1/10th the size of a piece of hair
are able to catch insects flying upwards of 15 miles an hour.
And, believe it or not, if a web were an inch thick in diameter
it could actually stop a fighter jet.
Strength, some spiders can lift up to 50 times their body weight, this muscle strength
is directly related to size.
Think about your biceps, when you work out it increases
in height and width, but not length.
In this way, the strength of an organism increases
as a square, or by 2 on the scale factor.
But as organisms get bigger, their volume increases by
height, width and length,
as a cube, or a 3 on the scale factor.
This creates a ratio of 2:3,
meaning the bigger the organism, the smaller its proportional strength.
But because Spider-man is human shaped and sized,
the retorvirus would have to encode for the creation of more
actin and myosin proteins.
These proteins effect the contraction abilities of muscles,
and in effect could make a human stronger.
Climbing walls? Not a problem for spiders,
they have tiny hairs on each leg
and these hairs have tons of even smaller
hairs with triangular ends
which interact within nanometers of the atoms on the surface.
This creates electrostatic forces, allowing them to stick with
strength of 170 times their own weight.
Too capture this ability, Spider-man would need permanently
hairy hands and feet,
which may not overly impress his damsels in distress.
And finally, what about the Spidey Sense?
Well, spider hairs are extremely sensitive
to vibration and air pressure changes.
But this means that spider-man could
only perceive things that are near him, and not events at a distance.
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments, or on facebook and twitter, and subscribe for
weekly science videos.